marsha has just opened her new computer
store she makes 27 on every computer she
sells and her monthly expenses are 10
what is the minimum number of computers
she used to sell in a month to make a
profit so i'll let you think about that
for a second
well let's think about what we have to
figure out we have to figure out the num
the minimum number of computers she
needs to sell so let's set that to a
variable or set a variable to represent
that so let's let x
equal the number of computers she sells
number of computers
computers sold
now let's think about how much net
profit she will make in a month and
that's what we're thinking about how
many how many computers the minimum
number sees to sell in order to make a
net profit
so i'll write her profit
her profit is going to be how much money
she brings in from selling in selling
the computers and she makes 27 on every
computer she sells so her profit is
going to be 27
times the number of computers she sells
she gets 27 per computer times the
number she sells
but we're not done yet she still has
expenses of 10 000
per month so we're gonna have to
subtract out
we're gonna have to subtract out the ten
thousand dollars what we care about is
making a profit we want this number
right over here to be greater than
zero
so let's just think about what number of
computers would get us to zero and then
she if maybe she's just a little bit
more than that
so let's say let's see what gets her to
break even
so break even that's zero profit neither
positive or negative is equal to 27
times and i'll do it all in one color
now 27x
minus
10 000. well we've seen equations like
this before we can add 10 000 to both
sides
add 10
to both sides so that it gets so it's no
longer on the right hand side
and we are left with
we are left with ten thousand
ten thousand
is equal to twenty
is equal to 27x and then to solve for x
we just have to divide both sides
by 27. so let's do that divide both
sides by 27.
on our right hand side we have x so let
me just write this down so we have x
on our right hand side is going to be
equal to 10 000 over 27
is going to be equal to 10 000 over 27.
i've switched the right and the left
hand sides here now what is this going
to be well we can do a little bit of
long division to handle that so 27
goes into 10 000.
so 27 doesn't go to one doesn't go into
10 it goes into 100 3 times
3 times 27
is what 81
100 minus 81 is 19
then we can bring down a zero
27 goes into 190 it looks like it'll go
into it about six times let's see if
that's right 6 times 7 is 42
6 times 2 is 12 plus 4
16. let's see 90 minus 62 is actually 20
28. oh yes let me let me turn this back
so it goes 7 times 7 times 7 is 49
7 times 2 is 14 plus 4 is 18. there you
go look at that so 190 minus 189 we get
one let's bring down another zero
we bring down
see we bring down another zero we have a
zero right there 27 goes into 10 how
many times what doesn't go into 10 at
all so put a zero right there
0 times 27 is 0 then we subtract and
then we get 10 again and now we're in
the decimal range or we're going to
start getting decimal values but we
could bring out another 0 we could get
27 goes into 100 three times
so
our x value is going to be approximately
370.3 and then we're going to keep going
on and on and on and on but this is
enough information for us to answer our
question what is the minimum number of
computers she needs to sell in a month
to make a profit
well she can't sell
a decimal number of computers a third of
a computer she could either sell 370
computers
if she sells 370 computers then she's
not going to get to break even because
that's less than the quantity she needs
for breakeven so she needs to sell 371.
she needs to sell 371 computers in a
month to make a profit